hello everyone and welcome to the second
game ever between Fabiana Khurana and
ding Lear and since you enjoyed their
first game so much it's again from 2016
toughest old masters as the previous one
was from the 2015 Tata Steel masters and
before we check out the game as our
warm-up for the candidates tournament I
would just like to say that the
subscribers video has been uploaded so
in case you've missed the notification
or in case you you haven't seen it for
some reason I will put a link to it in
the description below it will be the
first thing you will see so if you want
to check it out it's only 30 minutes
long and you know it's not safe to go
outside anyway so you might as well
check it out so without further ado
let's see what's happening here Fabi
with the white pieces opens with E 4 and
after well a fairly long theoretical
struggle we're gonna have a nice grind
we've a 5 by ding Knight f3 knight c6
and Bishop to b5 so the reuleaux pieces
on the board we have a 6 more fees
defense push up to a4 and now Knight to
f6
we have castles in Bishop e7 so all
standard stuff we have D 3 and B 5
they're pushing the bishop back push up
to b3 and now d6 now in here a3 making
room for the bishop on a2 as black will
usually go for Knight a5 he will push c5
and so on so tonight's the a5
immediately with Russia back to a tube
of course not interested in giving up
your light square bishop it is an
excellent piece c5 now grabbing more
space here and Knight to c3 we brush up
the e6 now offering a trade of light
squared bishop and now today Bishop to
g5 is the is the go-to move but in 2016
when this was playing Knight to the age
4 was played by Fabi
we have c4 biding also a usual moved in
and mount Knight to f5 and excellent
square for the knight
preparing to capture on g7 so black and
either Castle or capture on f5 and here
ding decides to give up the Adelaide
scoreboard with captures it captures on
f5 and there is one game where rook the
c8 was played but here dink castles and
it is as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so what what's
happening here well
dings night is on the edge of the board
so not really doing all that much and
fabi's light-square bishop is pretty
much boxed in so Bobby wants to do
something about it Saudi characters on
c4 and now Knight captures on c4 if you
could play this and keep this Bishop
well pretty much doing nothing and maybe
get a d5 in that would be great but
problem is the white will always have
Bishop to g5 and he will attack it just
attack one of the defenders of the d5
square and you do not have enough
support to push d5 so it would be a
problem for example if d5 you just
capture captures and you just pick up
the pawn so nothing going on here
so instead Knight captures on c4 biding
with Bishop captures now B captures and
the Bishop to g5 again preventing Dean
from executing d5 we have rook to b8
developing the rook also the b2 point is
undefended so rook the b1 Fabi defends
it and it's a good thing has opponent c4
so if any be for action then he can just
go see captors and b3 and Poisson we
have Knight 37 offering further trades
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Knight to d5 and it's it's always a
special moment in every chess players
life when you land that night and d5
always feels excellent especially I
don't know if you play a lot against
them maybe neither of Sicilian when you
get that Knight d5 in there always
always good stuff
so Queen back to d8 and now Queen to g4
and already Fabi has a very nasty set up
here if black isn't careful for example
if you try something like let's say
Knight b6 as here farm is just the
threatening to win the pawn amongst
other things but if you try and defend
it let's say Knight b6 now you get f6 in
and here's the problem after g6 you just
go 97 check King h8 and Queen h4 it's
gonna be it's gonna be a problem for for
black to defend this you're gonna have
to go night here so you can meet this
with the just captures but still you can
just play pretty much anything you can
go rook F e1 you can never capture
because Queen recaptures with Czech
you'll just go rook here rook III rock
h3 and it's gonna be a quick death for
black so instead after Queen to g4 ding
plays a very interesting more he plays
rook the b5 but
so just over clear you could also maybe
defend the pond we would rock the c8 but
this just loses terribly but even feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure out why it loses while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting this beautiful move in a
line that never actually happened and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show its f6 here f6 works because the
rook is placed and see it and now if you
get Knight captures first Queen captures
and c8 that's that's the killer move
Queen characters in 97 check now picks
up the Queen King h8 9 captures rook
captures and here far we would have 1 1
D exchange and pretty much the game if
played correctly so after Queen to g4
rook the b5 instead now putting pressure
on the night here and here just Queen
captures on c4 Bobby grabs upon and
night the b6 ding now offers a trade we
have captures Queen captures putting
pressure on the b2 pawn and now that the
c4 pawn has been eliminated Bobby can
finally play b4 and here d5 by dink we
have Queen to b3 and now Queen to c6
also interesting might be a rook rook to
b8 to put a lot of pressure here maybe
prepare a 5 the problem is a white can
go after the e5 pawn and let's say B for
the rook now defends the point now c4
and after characters captures the Queen
now gets away from the B file you also
put pressure on the e5 pawn and the
white white just keeps the pawn it and
is better so ding tries a different idea
he goes Queen to c6 he prepares the of
course d4 will be played and then he
prepares to have this square for the
rook and the Queen will be defending it
so first rook to e1 Bobby goes after
dings undefended pawn and now d4 also f6
is an idea but being prefers to keep the
pawn structure intact for now
d4 the rook now nicely defends the pawn
and now a for pushing dings rook back
and now rogue d5 preparing at some point
to go maybe e4 d3 and try and create a
passed pawn this way and here Bobby
starts with h4 also possible was just
straight b5 because after characters
captures the Queen is under attack let's
say the Queen moves somewhere
you can even as the Queen does have to
keep an eye on the rook now you push b6
and you already have a beautiful pass
pawn here it's hard to say if you will
be if you'll be able to keep it but even
if even if black starts going after you
can just bring the other rook over to b1
and dad that's a beautiful passport but
you have to decide whether it's
something you want to play so Fabi
instead goes h4 first and now Dean said
okay you don't what you didn't want to
play b5 you're not playing it now so
rook to b8 and now Queen to f3 putting
pressure on the rook so the Queen has to
keep defending it and also if you move
the rook then the Queen might hang so f6
just strengthening the pawn chain in the
center and now rook eat a d1 sorry rook
eat a d1 just saying that okay the cc2
pony's off-limits since the rook is
hanging and at some point well I know
you want to start pushing those pawns so
my rooks will be ready and it is also a
way to maybe do a nice roof lift would
work to do
or even rook the b3 depending on what
ding plays so Queen to c4 unpinning now
and also putting pressure on the on the
pawn here and the Queen to d3 Fabi now
offers the Queen trade he wants this
captures captures and out this pawn
nicely controls a dean spawn chain and
he's just gonna well either double up
here push push b5 or try somewhere away
but either way he's in a rooks endgame
being up a pawn and he has a two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side so now he is
very confident in playing this so after
Queen D 3 ding plays rook c8 instead now
he threatens just to pick up the pawn
here and the Ruby to Fabi defends it we
have looked back to d6 now defending the
a6 pawn and b5 now by Fabi we've looked
to b6 also one of the reasons for rook
to d6 so you can have this now of course
you cannot capture because the rook
hangs
but rook the a1 now so what do you play
here here the point is if you go eight
characters on b5 for example characters
captures and then rook captures on b5
it's not possible due to captures with
check and then captures you you simply
blunder a look so this is the idea so
instead we have h5 being just prevents
from further pushing the H point and now
we have looked a three a nice truck lift
saying that okay now if you capture I
can even capture with the Queen but
basically I can also double up rooks on
the B file this way we have Queen to be
five now Dean avoids the Queen trade and
now is ready to start pushing with E for
so rook a to be three Bobby says I'm
ready for efore idea as I have some
ideas of my own so the input is efore we
have Queen to be one now with tempo as
the opponent h5 hangs and rook to d8 now
Dean says okay you go after the point
I'm just gonna start pushing my passport
well soon-to-be created created pass
pawn here Fabi says okay I'm not waiting
for this d3 move I'm just gonna go for B
captures on a6 so what's what's
happening here we have route captors and
a6 biding and now you could go for the
h5 point for example Queen captures here
Luke captures here and then basically
you have a nice attack with white for
example after Luke to b7 it's hard to
say if black will be able to parry all
the threats but then again it's a lot to
take in as d3 is coming and that will be
one one well very passed passed pawn so
after Luke captures on a6 instead far
because rugby 5 he keeps he he wants to
keep the a4 pawn and start pushing it we
have Queen to d6 and now a 5 he says I
can always capture on h5 it's not a
problem but now adding also takes his
opportunity for d3 and okay characters
captures now Dean created a passport in
d3 whereas Fabi has a passed pawn on e5
and Fabi still up upon so something
definitely to consider Rudy to Bobby
doesn't allowed him to push it all the
way to d2 and now rook the c6 again with
ideas of maybe going rook to c2 so we
have looked the b3 now with ideas of
just capturing this pawn but now Queen
c7 threatening just the captured upon
but also rook the c1 would win the Queen
for example if you go captures then just
captures captures and of course rook to
see one wins the game so after Queen c7
we have looked back to b1 and now adding
has to decide whether he wants the
capture on e5 or he wants to keep and
keep the pond for example he could go
for this
this defense the pond but then either we
would have a repetition with rugby three
route back to c6 or we would have looked
the a1 which would result again in
trading everything for example after a
six
after rooked a sex blocking you would
have captures and after captures
captures just captures and here of
course if white wants he can go captures
captures and we would have the same game
where fabi's up upon but it's a queen
queen a queen opponent game where he has
a double the F pawn so chances are doing
would be able to hold this but it's it's
hard to say Queens Queens a queen
opponent games are extremely complicated
but the DHing doesn't like this instead
he goes for Queen captures on a5 he
wants to keep as much material on the
board as possible we have rook captures
on d3 and now look D to c8 so keeping
everything on the board but now if Abby
says okay I'm just gonna grab a second
point as well Queen captures on h5 and
okay Queen B five now Dean covers the h2
square and he's going for some rook the
rook to c1 check ideas but it doesn't
really do much since you can always just
bring the rook but Fabi doesn't even
wait for it Fiber goes rook BD one
doubles here so he also has some threats
here along the this file but now rook
the c1 by dink and now again what do you
play here we have Queen Queen back to f3
if you try something like this check
this is pretty much pointless if any of
you were considering this because well
it's not so much pointless but after
this capture you you cannot capture here
of course because the rock is pinned you
have to capture on c1 and then basically
we just traded down but it is definitely
playable so instead of going for this
fob we first went Queen to f3 he just
wants to keep the material on the board
but rook captures and e1 not Queen
captures but rather look after sandy one
the Queen has to keep an eye on the f5
pawn and now Quinta e8 so we here again
have a and get an ending where ding is
down two points in the pawns now instead
of that Queen opponent again where he
could have been down one pawn but I
don't think King was interested in a
draw here I think I think ding play ding
is playing this for a win maybe not
anymore but he definitely was so g3
Fabi just improves his position we have
worked the c5 now at least they might
try and win one of the pawns back but
looked a 1 now with the threat of rook
to e8 as the Queen also guards the 8
square so Queen to d7 getting out of the
way but now rotate check with rook back
to c8 and now rook the a5 still not
confident in in trading down as again
it's it's Queen and Queen with four
points against Queen and two points you
know anything can happen there
so King to h7 and now rook to d5 pushing
the Queen back queenie 8 and now King g2
just improving the position we looked
the c7 now trying to create some sort of
a barrier on the seventh rank but Bobby
has a plan against there as well again
rook a five goes after a eight we have
Queen to f7 and now Queen to d5 and this
is a beautiful move Queen d5 which
basically forces a trade because if you
move the Queen then a row K it is deadly
and then Queen Quinta g8 the Queen to g8
is coming and you are quickly getting
checkmated so after Queen d5 ding has to
go into a rook and pawn in the game
Queen captures with check rook captures
and now rook the c4 but now it's a it's
a real component game where Bobby has
four points ending only has two and it's
not an easy one to hold we have Rudy -
but now King g8 with f3 starting to pull
those pawns King to f8 with g4 by Fabi
and rook the c1 with King to g3 root 2 G
1 check but now rook the G 2 of course
the King and pawn and game would be
winning for Fabi
so ding declines the trade of course we
have looked back to a1 and now g5 king
of 7 we have King to g4 rook to a4 with
check with f4 now
just keeping everything closed F
captures and g5 now of course you have
to capture with the h1 you cannot under
your pawns as due to the pin so H
capture sin g5 and now again root k1
dink can only wait and see what fob is
plan is we have grouped to be 2
preparing to check the black king away
so the white king can make an appearance
here look the g1 with check we have king
h3 now ready to meet rook h1 check with
- gee - so look back the f1 going after
the pond but now rugby 7 check King f8
and now king g4 so nicely done
so now if rules you want check now you
can get a lot a lot of moves in with the
king
so rook h1 instead not allowing this
entry but now f6 and here G captures an
f6 and then now of course not capturing
the pawn if you capture the point then
it's a problem rook checks King at five
and just rook h1 and you don't have a
way to make progress here for example if
you go in with the king just check you
have to go back and then the rook h1
yeah it's not not not possible to make
progress here
so instead after this G captors on f6
move of course Fabi went for g6 but now
rook to a1 and now King f5 of course you
want to get rid of that pawn so look the
a6 defending and now rook f7 check King
g8 and now not capturing even though it
is possible to capture first rookie 7
preparing to probably block and then
capture with the king we have rook to a
4 now if the King captures you can
capture with check but now rook to e4
blocking look back to a6 and the now
look the e6 again we have rook to a four
ding repeats but of course now Fabi has
to play something so he captures and now
it's two points against no points of
course this is a very easily played so
Brooke a5 check King to g4 and now King
to g7 we have rook the d6
and the now comes rook to a1 came to g5
and now rook the g1 with check came to
f5 and now came to h6 and here
Fabi just played rook to d8 and it was
in this position that England resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here if you're thinking about why
not capture the pawn I'm I know none of
you are thinking that but maybe some of
you are so if you capture the pawn do
you see what's the easiest way for white
to win even even pause the video and try
to find it so you you know you will be
able to spot it straight on in your own
games so for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on spotting it
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's locate a check just
so you know this
the only sequence that wins King here
and now rook checks captures captures
and of course the ending is completely
winning for wife King fhr gonna pull the
punk in here you put the pawn king here
and now finally f7 and you forced the
King away King g7 King g7 and you Queen
the pawn sir
after this rook to b8 move link resigned
and another excellent victory for
Fabiano Caruana
in their second ever encounter which
occurred in 2016 Tata Steel masters
edition so just in case you forgot the
final standings of the 2016 talis two
masters edition here they are
it was also won by Magnus Carlsen like
the 2015 Tata Steel masters but here
Fabiana Khurana in being Lear and tied
for second so even then two of them
really showed that they were ready to
take on the the top elite of the chess
world and we're not gonna be showing any
more games between ding and Fabi until
we start with the actual twenty20
candidates tournament but if you want or
if you've maybe skipped that or if
you're new to the channel also below the
link of the subscribers video twenty20 I
will put a clash between ding and Fabi
from the 2019 Norway chess was really
really a wild game so do check it out if
you want you know maybe someone else
will win in that matchup but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Ryan better Bradley
Campbell Robert Nara and Taylor
Stephen Porter and Lars Elstad lien for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing with the
Morphy saga continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
the candidates are almost here so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day